es la materialización de la política
carcelaria de nayib bukele y el símbolo
de lo que ha denominado como guerra
contra el crimen en El Salvador se trata
del centro de confinamiento del
terrorismo la mega prisión que inauguró
bukele a comienzos de febrero tiene la
capacidad para 40.000 personas se
encuentra a 74 kilómetros de la capital
del país San Salvador los pabellones son
rodeados por un muro de concreto de 11
metros de altura y de 2,1 kilómetros de
largo el centro ha sido ensalzado como
uno de los principales logros de su
administración una que ha defendido como
parte fundamental de su lucha contra la
delincuencia esta comenzó su ascenso
desde que el congreso controlado por
fuerzas oficialistas aceptó decretar el
estado de excepción en El Salvador en
marzo 2022 la medida se ha prorrogado en
11 ocasiones y le otorga unas facultades
extraordinarias al presidente del país
según cifras del gobierno se han
arrestado 64,000 presuntos criminales
pertenecientes sobre todo a las maras
salvatrucha y 18 una política defendida
por bukele incluso frente a la ONU El
Salvador ha pasado de ser el país más
peligroso del mundo
literalmente el país más peligroso del
mundo
a estar en camino a ser el país más
seguro de América organizaciones
protectoras de derechos humanos han
alzado sus voces en contra de los
procedimientos del gobierno salvadoreño
cómo lo muestra un informe de Human
right watch publicado en diciembre del
año pasado el informe documenta
detenciones arbitrarias masivas torturas
y otras formas de maltrato contra
personas detenidas desapariciones
forzadas muertes bajo custodia y
procesos penales abusivos a pesar de lo
polémico de las medidas estas siguen
siendo defendidas por una buena parte de
la población bukele terminó 2022 con una
aprobación de más del 87%